let's talk to megan in kansas city
missouri megan what's going on
hey dr john thank you so much for taking
my call i was really
excited to chat with kelly this morning
but i guess i can talk to you too
well played i see what you did there
i think i should probably be a little
nicer to you because i need some advice
i disagree kelly's
she's the brains behind this show
so what's up how can i help so my
husband and i need some parenting advice
we are the parent to the sweetest
cutest smartest most tenacious funniest
sassiest eight-year-old little girl
um and we have some concerns about her
weight okay
um so she's eight she on her growth
chart has really been pacing sixty
percent for height ninety percent for
weight for really her entire life since
she's been tracked
okay um and so we have some concerns
about her weight she kind of started to
outpace her height
growth growth and so we brought our
concerns to her pediatrician
and we had a candid conversation with
her without her around
um and just said you know we're really
kind of concerned you know we have our
own family struggles with obesity
and we've been on our own health journey
but we we want better for her
and so we have been referred to our
local children's hospital to a weight
management clinic
um and so here are my two questions is
this something that we should pursue
if so how in the world do we have this
an age-appropriate conversation with an
eight-year-old about her body
in a really healthy empowering way we
really do not want to
hurt her in the process of trying to
help her gotcha
number one this one's hard and so i
appreciate your trust here man
and it's out man i can hear it over the
phone you love this kid don't you
oh gosh and let's i just want to call
out the beginning of this
call anything weight discussion is just
so sensitive
and so i'm going to just go blaze right
through the middle of this okay
and if i don't say it the right way or
if i
will lean one way please just know my
heart is with you
and your husband and this beautiful
beautiful daughter okay
um so anytime i i have this conversation
anything health related to a kid
especially someone who's like eight and
not eighteen
i always wanna know the percentiles
right which you gave me 60 to 90 and it
sounds like the 90
is increasing right you know it's
increasing by
probably two to three percent okay um
you know i mean it's not
exploding uh but it's not going in the
right direction right okay
so this is a hard question where did she
learn this
where was this where where so
um especially childhood obesity would
fall under a disordered eating
right whether it's a coping tool or
whether it's just available or whether
it's a combination of
500 different factors where does she
learn this either modeling or see it do
you and your husband have weight
challenges like walk me through you and
your husband's journey
yeah so um my pediatrician put me on my
first diet when i was five years old
um and so i've got a pretty interesting
history with my weight
um and so i was on a diet from five to
thirty i had bariatric surgery at 30.
hold on
i don't want to say very interesting i
want to use the word trauma
oh yeah for sure okay not just
interesting i don't want to minimize it
that's hard five-year-olds should not be
on diets
right right right um and so
i have bariatric surgery at 30. i've
maintained a hundred pound weight loss
for the past six years
awesome um my husband had bare extra
surgery about three years ago he's also
maintained a hundred pound weight loss
we have about seven members of our
extended family who have had bariatric
surgery
and who have all maintained about a
hundred pound weight loss for a
significant amount of time
awesome so if if there's an obesity gene
i'm pretty sure we have that
okay um but
we have in our family we don't
personally have been in our family we've
got ty 2 diabetes
and um heart conditions and all of the
things that go along with it so i would
say she probably learned it from us
even though i feel like i've been hyper
vigilant
on her eating and on her exercise and in
her relationship with her body
and i feel like we're doing a lot of
really great things with her nutrition
and bodytalk and um
things like that like it's like we're
really regimen and we're still
struggling and she's still
really struggling here gotcha so is
the so when you talk about you've
maintained a hundred
pound weight number one high five to you
that's incredible
okay and i'm gonna i feel like i'm the
both and guy always right
so that's incredible and i've seen it
to where maintaining the hundred pound
weight loss becomes the new drug
and because the regimen and the
militantness becomes the new pathology
is that you guys or have you for those
who don't know disorder eating is
so hard because like if you're addicted
to cocaine
you can just stop being around cocaine
you can't do that with food you've got
to make peace with it
right and that's a whole other level are
you in a healthy place with food or is
it something that you've learned to
control
through power i am very very very
regimented with my food i treat
i treat my relationship food with food i
almost should like a food addiction
like i don't eat any form of sugar even
stevia
because one bite is not enough it's on
i mean i'm out yeah um and so i eat
three meals a day
no snacks i weigh and measure my food i
have to be regimented
because i live in a brain that says too
much is not enough
and so i can hit a slippery slope fast
yes
um is your husband similar no
no he is way more balanced with it than
i am okay
and he's maintained his weight loss okay
so you um did he have the same childhood
you had
no he really didn't no he didn't he
was i mean a fairly you know average
weight kid he really started gaining in
like high school in college
um and then he had brain cancer a couple
years ago and has an autoimmune disease
and because of the medicine that he
takes it caused some weight gain
and so that was a lot of the catalyst
behind it
okay have you ever met with a
psychologist or a counselor for any
extended period of time
oh i've gone for years okay
so when somebody tells me they've gone
for years and
the so the their their day-to-day life
is still
so controlled by this narrative
there's a gap there what is that gap
what do you think that is
so we i've probably gone pretty
consistently for three maybe four years
and we have unpacked a lot of family
history our
trauma that i went through so we've
spent probably the first three years
impacting family trauma
and now have really spent the past
probably six months to a year
talking through my relationship with
food and really unpacking my
relationship with food and how i handle
it okay so
there if if every single person in your
family
i don't wanna i can't i'm not a medical
doctor so i cannot rule out
any sort of genetic disposition
any sort of medical conditions that you
and your family have okay so you
know about that your pediatrician knows
about your kids pediatrician knows about
that okay
what i can tell you is kids absorb
and when i say absorb i mean they
inhale it it's the air they breathe they
inhale
home tension and they inhale
home peace in a
really weird way and it becomes them in
a really weird way
and i don't know enough to tell you
about
um weight and how that works i just
don't know enough
right um but i will use something like
adhd
if you have you hear a lot about that's
a neurological condition
it's a genetic issue
it is only in the right context in the
right environments
right so in a particular brain i'm a
card-carrying member of that crew
so in a particular chaotic
or exhausted or power
or whatever childhood you want to wrap
your head around
my brain went to solve problems that way
right which then leads to all sorts of
anxiety issues and all sorts of this and
this is i try to sit still in a
classroom for eight hours and then hold
a job and all those other things right
and so it may be this is me just
spitballing here not medical advice
that your kid absorbs chaos tension
regiment power and
because of the series of of genes that
that she inherited
her outlet becomes x right as though
minds is why
right it doesn't mean we're broken it
means our body's doing exactly what they
were designed to do
at some point that means that the focus
in your world
has got to shift and this is so so so
hard
has to shift away from fighting and
towards peace and i'm so
so happy to hear you are on that journey
right the fact that a five-year-old was
put on a diet
for 25 years and nobody said hey is this
working
right what i mean that's such a
traumatic thing that was done to you and
i'm so so sorry that you experienced
that
i hate that for you hate it hate it hate
it
and my hope and dream is i'm very
similar
if i have one gummy candy dude i will
i'll eat everything right um
and i also know i can do that sometimes
and it's gonna be all right nobody's
you know and then i'm gonna be back on
my cycle so i've made peace with it
right and that's what i long
long for you so getting back to your
daughter eight-year-olds can't make
peace
they don't they're eight right
is your physician worried about your
daughter's health is he scared for her
or is he
listening to your family history and
listening to your fear about your
daughter
he's listening to me okay
so when he said or she recommended that
to go to a clinic what does that mean is
that an outpatient clinic is she going
to go live there for six months what is
that going to be
no what it is is we will meet with a
doctor
and a dietitian via zoom and so she did
labs this morning they're gonna look at
her labs look at her medical history do
some genetic testing to see if she has
an obesity gene
um and then she so there is a
genetic predisposition right there is
that that actual gene i'm sure
yes i'm sure there is and she hasn't
been tested for it but i
if i was a betting woman i would bet
that she probably died i don't know
enough about
obesity genes to know so i trust you
that there's there and so then my guess
is
just look in epigenetics that a whole
host of people may have that gene
but given the right set of trauma and
circumstances and filling the blanket on
the blank then that sucker
right gets activated and here we go okay
yeah um and so we're gonna meet with
them we'll be paired with a
pediatric dietitian and then there are
also some peer groups that she will be a
part of and like meet with zoom while
they'll talk through like
um activity and what are some good food
choices
and things like that and kind of walk
her through that they also are doing a
research study
and which is why they're going to do
genetic testing they're also doing a
research study
um to track her and track kids in their
program
through their adolescence to see who has
the gene
how they respond to treatment
and who doesn't how they respond because
i think that their but from what they
said there's a lot of research
on prevention there's not a lot of
research on damage control when we're
already here
not a lot of research about how to get
out of here yeah
so can i ask you this question this is
gonna sound like an indicting question
it's not at all
how did your daughter get here it sounds
like you have a really regimented home
that wouldn't have sugar in all the
breads and all the stuff in it
and yet somehow she still found herself
here
how did she is is it just her body's
response to
protein intake and healthy saturated fat
intake i mean
how does she can be it can't be it can't
be that i mean it has to be us i mean
there's times where well
i mean we probably eat out probably
twice a month she gets ice cream a
couple times a month
um but there are times where you know
we're
not as regimented i mean for the most
part we're probably 80 really regimented
and 20
not and so she had to have gotten here
because of us
where her environment like but megan's
higher hand and i left
80 wouldn't get you here 80
would it would be a 20 like just using
the math
i want to stay in my lane here and i
don't know enough about the medical
but an 80 like we're living in 80 20
life
in a normal circumstance would not
equate to
a 90 to 94 93 percentile
does that make sense yeah what's that
gap what am i missing
i i mean it's easily that we could not
have been
as regimented as we have been in
probably the past year and so
it could be that i mean it could be i
don't i wish i knew if i knew i would
have fixed this already
okay what i i want you to be
really careful about that language that
you just said okay
anytime and you've lived this
anytime somebody becomes a project or
something to fix
because they are broken that becomes
trauma for the rest of their life
okay okay your daughter's just
i mean you love her so much i can hear
it right
here's the person i want you to love too
i want you to love you
you've accomplished so much but it feels
like you are still
working so so so hard
is that right bad eyes
after all of your success and turning
the corner
you still don't like you why is that
i don't know i think i feel like i have
to earn
and i have to prove myself and earn
that love and prove that i'm successful
yeah you don't got to earn nothing and
somebody told you that a lot of people
have told you that
what you need you need to do is you need
to eat better what you need to do is you
need to lose some weight and what you
need to do is
whatever and for some of us like
we were told to achieve academically we
were told to achieve on a ball field you
were told to achieve
in a dinner table and that's bullcrap
but i'm so sorry that happened to you
my mom used to tell me it'd be really
pretty um if i would lose weight
that was the cutest cutest one here
green eyed little girl
i'm so sorry i want to do this to my
daughter i know you know so much
i want so much better for her and here's
where you start
you start with your mirror okay
now there's some very practical things
that y'all are gonna have to work
through as a family
right her weight is her weight and her
challenges are her challenges
right y'all have to work that
practically
but she is going to learn how to love
herself
by the most important gigantic model she
has in the world and that's you
she's going to learn how to love her
future partner she's going to learn how
to
love food she's going to learn how to
love laughing learn how to
do all things from you
and if you say you got to love yourself
she will not be able to
know cognitively but she will sense the
disconnect between what you're saying
and how
you look at yourself
okay that's not an indictment that is
i'm telling you that not to pile more
crap on you because you do not need that
i'm telling you that to let you know
that your husband loves you
your little girl loves you and the world
is waiting on megan to love megan
you don't gotta achieve nothing nothing
okay okay
and you've listened to the show long
enough i'll tell you the truth if i
think you're being an idiot i'll tell
you the truth
okay okay now
here's the hard reality your daughter is
is somehow get
she doesn't feed herself she's somehow
getting this stuff here
um she's absorbing this stuff and i
think
um i don't have any problem with any
sort of if
if a medical doctor says hey we need to
do a clinic intake i'm in no position to
override a medical doctor
what i would love to see is and
hopefully it would be a part of this
protocol
i'd love to see some sort of family
counseling with the three of you
maybe starting with you and your husband
and then
moving over to include your daughter
okay because something i want to get
underneath this the symptoms here
underneath the eating underneath the
um the physiology here underneath that
and say what do we how can we
a resource for one another of peace
right not not
weighing everything you got you may have
to do that that may be the rest of your
life i hope
it's not and i hope the counselor you're
with psychologists with is making peace
with
not learning to get tougher right being
vulnerable with
um
and you've got to deal with the medical
stuff with your daughter i keep saying
that over and over
but here's the thing you all have to
model a different life
and if that works through if that begins
with her going to this
program great and if it doesn't great
how you tell her
is just that you love her
love love love love her one thing i tell
my kids all the time
they've got one job i've got one job and
that's me helping them be safe
i'll say what's my one job and they'll
roll their eyes back keep me safe
right um i want you to let your daughter
know that you love her
and that you want her to be so so so so
well and so healthy
and that you're working on being healthy
that daddy's still working on being
healthy
and you're gonna help her learn some new
tools and how she can be healthy
okay and you're gonna start from there
any sort of
hiding or lying to a kid they will
absorb it they will make it their fault
and they'll chase that down for the rest
of our lives you gotta tell her the
truth
okay okay but also parents can weaponize
that
like it was done to you right you know
what i mean by that
yeah you'd be so pretty if you'd be so
pretty if you could just loosen
that stops in your heart right you're
not going to pass that one on right
never awesome so it becomes
i want to we want to have a healthy
family that is always able to run and
play and laugh
and get old and be able to hang out with
our dog whatever the thing is
right this is about building a beautiful
wonderful healthy life
not running from an ugly one okay
and let's make no mistake too your
daughter knows that she doesn't look
like other kids
is that fair that's totally fair yeah
so we're gonna focus less on the
aesthetics less on beauty because she is
beautiful
and wonderful and spunky and fire but
we're gonna focus less on that stuff
we're gonna focus more on building
something beautiful okay
okay okay hey she is really lucky to
have you as her mom
thank you and that
knucklehead husband of yours is really
lucky to have you as his wife
thank you so much okay okay i'm so
grateful that you called megan thank you
so much